لا تهدر الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده وقتا
في ضعف النظام القضائي في اسرائيل حيث
فجرت جدلا في الساحتين السياسيه والقضائيه
باطلاق خطتها التي تنص على تشريع قانون
يغلب قرارات الكنيست اي السياسيين على
قرارات القضاء وتامين اغلبيه بواقع سبعه
من اصل 11 عضو في لجنه تعيين القضاء لصالح
الائتلاف والغاء ما يسمى بفقره المعقوليه
في الاحكام القضائيه التي تحمل الافراد
والمجموعات من تنفيذ او عدم تنفيذ الحكومه
قرارات تؤثر في حياتهم
انت مين
تطبيق السياسه التي وعدنا بها الجمهور
وانتخبنا من اجلها واعتقد بان مواطني
اسرائيل يشعرون بذلك جيدا لقد فكرنا حكومه
مختلفه ولها سياسه وغيره وتتصرف على نحو
مختلف في المعارضه اعتبرو ان الحكومه بدات
انقلاب على النظام القضائي والسياسي
لمساعده نتنياهو في محاكمته الجاريه
بقضايا فساد وخلق ديكتاتوريه الاغلبيه
التي تهضم حقوق الاقليات والافراد وبدات
في النزول الى الشارع للتظاهر اسبوعيا
والمحكمه ستتالف من مقربين للسلطه
السياسيون سيعيون قضاه خانعيين ينفدون ما
يطلب منهم سيكون انقلابا خطيرا على نظام
الحكم جل النقاش يطال الاغلبيه اليهوديه
الفلسطينيه داخل اسرائيل في ظل وجود تمييز
تعترف به الحكومات المتعاقبه
اثنين تعتبر عنصريه مثل قانون القوميه
الذي يعرف اسرائيل بانها دوله لليهود لا
لجميع مواطنها وهو سقف اداء الجهاز
القضائي الاسرائيلي ايضا بحقهم
الحكومه المتطرفه في اسرائيل تحاول
اخضاعها النظام القضائي والغاء الحدود بين
السلطتين القضائيه وتنفيذيه لصالح الاخيره
فيما تستغل المعارضه معارضه معظم الشارع
الاسرائيلي وفق استطلاعات الراي للحرب على
القضاء لجر المواجهه الى الشارع زياد حلبي
العربيه القدس الغربيه